[Musique]
on
bonjour nous sommes ensemble jusqu'à
13h30 chaque samedi politique avec un
point d'exclamation 45 minutes
d'entretien avec celles et ceux qui font
la politique alors que nous sommes à
bientôt cinq mois du premier tour de la
présidentielle ce midi nous recevons
françois bayrou bonjour
bonjour vous êtes en direct et en duplex
de votre ville de pau
maire de pau donc mais aussi plusieurs
fois ministre président du modem est
depuis un peu plus d'un an au
commissaire au plan nommé par emmanuel
macron avec vous françois bayrou on va
parler évidemment de ce que devrait être
la france dans dix vingt ou trente ans
on a du temps pour cela mais d'abord je
devrais je voudrais qu'on aille tout de
suite à la présidentielle vous avez été
candidat trois fois à l'elysée
2002-2007 2012 pas il ya spa il ya cinq
ans et donc pas en 2022 est ce à dire
sur un plan disons personnelles que vous
avez renoncé à devenir un jour président
de la république française c'est drôle
parce que c'est une question qui revient
aussi souvent que je vais vous faire une
réponse que j'ai déjà fait
dans ma vie de citoyen parce que c'est
ça que nous sommes vous moi ceux qui
nous écoutent des citoyens dans ma vie
de citoyen il n'y a pas de place pour le
renoncement à rien
je fais ce que je crois être nécessaire
et l'idée que je pourrais tirer un trait
sur un l'engagement de ma vie quelle que
soit la forme qu'il prend et qu'il sera
ou peut-être à mai à prendre cette idée
n'est pas la mienne je pense qu'on est
citoyens de plein exercice et que dans
cette citoyenneté eh bien on fait ce
qu'on croit devoir faire le devoir le
l'engagement le la responsabilité le
partage des responsabilités
tout cela c'est la vie d'un citoyen
chacun à sa place et chacun comme il
pense être le mieux je le disais on est
à cinq mois du premier tour quel rôle
vous comptez jouer dans cette campagne
celle d'un d'un citoyen engagé c'est une
campagne dont vous voyez bien le
l'enjeu ne l'extrême
enfin le caractère crucial
tout le monde voit bien ce qui est en
train de se passer une société française
dont se révèle désormais aux yeux de
tous des faiblesses qui chemine à bas
bruit comme on dit depuis des années et
des années depuis des décennies il ya
des décennies que ce que nous avons sous
les yeux se prépare qui lie à une
fermentation dans la société
qui est révélatrice de beaucoup de
problèmes et de beaucoup de faiblesses 7
ce mal français qui est aujourd'hui un
mâle de tous les pays développés en
vérité
ce mal français
c'est précisément ce qui va servir de
cadre sous c'est la question qui va être
la question principale de l'élection
présidentielle est-ce qu'on peut
rompre tourner la page sur ce mal
français
retrouvez une période où une époque qui
soit
2,2 fois dans l'avenir de confiance dans
l'avenir de certitudes que nous sommes
un peuple soudé et qu'il va relever tous
les défis qui se présentent à lui moi je
crois qu'on peut le faire je crois que
je crois que ce grand tournant
il est il est possible il est
souhaitable bien entendu et il est à
portée de la main c'est sur un plan
politique est ce à dire que lorsqu'il
sera candidat on vous verra aux côtés du
président macron faire campagne tenir
meeting en tout cas je suis engagé
auprès du président de la république
parce qu'il me paraît sans conteste
aujourd'hui être celui qui a le plus de
de force de caractère le plus de
volonté le plus de conscience
des difficultés et les incroyables crise
qu'il a traversés dans l'est dans les
quatre années et demie qui viennent de
s'écouler le montre et je ne vois pas
qui peut offrir au pays
une un avenir une horizon une volonté
qu'ils soient semblables ou du même
niveau que celles que emmanuel macron
peux t'offrir le jour où il aura décidé
de se présenter je le disais tout à
l'heure vous avez participé à trois
campagnes présidentielles quel regard
vous portez sur ce début de campagne
aujourd'hui où l'on débat par exemple du
maréchal pétain
de l'identité française ou un un
polémiste pas encore candidat occupe une
part importante de l'espace médiatique
quel regard vous portez là dessus
je vous le disais je trouve que tous ces
désordres
chemine depuis longtemps
ce n'est pas nouveau ça n'est pas neuf
je vous rappelle qu'il y a 20 ans
en avril 2 le 21 avril 2002 on a eu des
surprises du même ordre
et donc ces mots ne sont pas neufs mais
pour la première fois il se révèle aux
yeux de tous on ne peut plus les ignorer
et je trouve vous allez trouver choquant
ce que je dis je trouve que cette ce
dévoilement de la vérité est une
finalement une bonne nouvelle au bout du
compte ça nous oblige à ne plus accepter
les bandeaux que nous avons sur le sur
les yeux à regarder les choses en face
alors vous dites il ya des problèmes qui
tourne autour de l'identité française
sans aucun doute il ya des problèmes qui
tourne autour de l'identité dans tous
les pays qui nous entourent dans tous
les pays développés qui nous entoure et
aussi dans bien d'autres pays le chez
lesquels parmi les pays développés parmi
ceux qui ne le sont pas ou pas encore
lee dans la question de l'identité
tourne à une névrose
à une à une maladie de deux lames est ce
que c'est ce qui se passe en france
aujourd'hui
en partie oui mais je c'est bizarre je
je n'arrive pas je suis comme vous savez
mère d'une d'une ville responsable
de communauté politique importante chez
nous au pied des pyrénées donc on est
sans doute loin des loin de 2
départir des très grandes agglomérations
qui sont en crise plus profonde mais moi
je pense que le que le chemin non
seulement existe mais qu'il est
atteignable et que le l'espèce de
perpétuels dépression dans lesquelles
dans laquelle on veut nous plonger c'est
pas la réalité ce que jean ce que
j'envoie et dans de multiples parties de
la france et de l'europe où j'ai
rencontré des concitoyens ce que
j'envoie n'a pas le caractère
complètement déstabilisé de ceux de ce
qu'on nous dépeint et de ce qu'on nous
raconte donc
oui la france traverse une crise de cet
ordre mais cette crise là
on peut en sortir on peut la regarder en
face et on peut en sortir à condition
d'accepter de poser les questions comme
elle se pose vous parliez de l'identité
moi je pense que il ya un droit à
l'identité pour une société pour un
peuple il ya un droit j'ai écrit ça dans
plusieurs livres de morts dans les
années passées
ya un droit pour une société à a
souhaité que ces modes de vie ses
valeurs comme on dit entre guillemets le
monde est un peu fourre tout est un peu
valises il ya un droit ce que ces
valeurs se perpétue dans l'avenir à ce
que les femmes et les hommes
pensent que
demain ne sera pas
l'effacement de tout ce qu'ils ont
construit ensemble
et vous savez bien les très grands
auteurs qui sont pour moi très important
peggy par exemple
c'est exactement ce qu'il ce qu'il porte
ce qu'ils disent est donc cette ce désir
là où cette attente la est une attente
scène ce qui n'est pas sain et qui n'est
pas normal et kid
extraordinairement dangereux c'est de
passer sa vie à jeter a versé de
l'essence sur les braises parce que là
vous êtes sûr qu'on va aller vers
un incendie destructeur françois bayroux
eric zemmour qui selon les informations
de nos confrères de france inter
pourrait annoncer sa candidature dans
les prochains jours depuis colombey les
deux églises avec évidemment une
référence au général de gaulle de gaulle
ça vous choque c'est une provocation à
spa on peut pas à la fois
ceux se vêtir au moins dans les mots de
de la toge
du général de gaulle de ce que le
général de gaulle cette figure
historique incroyable a apporté à la
france et en même temps défendre
précisément tous ceux qui ont essayé
toute leur vie de détruire l'oeuvre du
général de gaulle de
prétendre se prétendent
de la famille même lointaine du général
de gaulle en ce en se faisant le
défenseur du pire dans pétain
comment commencer comment c'est possible
en prétendant que péta c'est ce qu'il a
fait c'était pour sauver les juifs
français comme s'ils étaient
indifférents de livrer des enfants juifs
étrangers
étrangers européens étant en plus voisin
de la même culture delà de la même
manière de vivre nous sommes ici dans
les pyrénées atlantiques y avait comme
vous savez sans doute un des grands
camps de concentration
français c'est le camp de gurs 1 que
nous que nous honorons et que nous
voulons que nous voulons présenter à
ceux à ce qui nous entoure on en ferme
et là des enfants juifs avant de les
expédier
le le le le nombre de deux de très
grands esprits qui avait à cette époque
qui étaient stigmatisés parce que il
appartenait à cette culture et à cette
communauté juive par exemple anna rentes
elle a été enfermée en clans de gurs
et vous croyez que que c'est un
différent d'avoir été de ce côté-là de
ceux qui enfermaient de ceux dont
l'autorité le le prestige
couvrait ses abominations vous croyez
que c'est un différend de deux de
pouvoir défendre cela et se dire en même
temps se prétendre
du côté du général de gaulle mais deux
de quelle incroyable imposture on part
rien d'incroyable
dévoiement de la vérité vous disiez tout
à l'heure la vérité éclate enfin
avec quels mots pouvez vous qualifier et
règlements
on sait d'eux
tout le monde parmi nous connaît eric
zemmour depuis des décennies c'est un un
journaliste
intellectuellement agile
avec des prises de position et peut à
prix s'est laissé enfermer dans son
propre piège
il est devenu amoureux de sa propre
dérive
il sait il ce est
enivré
de ce qui est pour moi
[Musique]
historiquement
terrible danger pour la pour la société
française et pour la france et pour
l'image de la france je me suis fâché
l'autre jour parce que
les organisateurs d'une journée qui
s'appelait
la journée des conservateurs je crois
avait invité zemmour mais seymour ça
n'est pas conservateur zemmour c'est
quelqu'un qui porte la subversion qui
essaient de détruire ce qu'est le plus
précieux de l'héritage français
et donc alors vous voyez bien
évidemment ce comment ça peut régaler un
certain nombre de gens mais ceci est un
danger épouvantable pour notre pays pour
notre nation et pour ce qu'elle a
apporté au monde alors of france à
beyrouth si on regarde ce qui se passe
maintenant au centre il ya donc ce ce
projet de maison commune c'est toujours
comme ça qu'on l'appelle d'ailleurs 18
mois non mais vous connais parce qu'on
n'a pas encore
il n'y a pas encore de deux noms en tout
cas il y aura un fixe et arrêter de
dévoiler en tout cas un rapprochement
entre votre parti le le modem et la
république en marche dader quel
calendrier
bah on a toujours dit depuis le depuis
le premier jour nous avons lancé cette
idée on a toujours dit avant noël dont
d'ici fin novembre décembre on peut
imaginer devoir officialisé ce
rapprochement cas quelle est la
philosophie derrière robin c'est très
simple
et
pardonnez moi de le dire c'est c'est
essentiel
il y as au centre de la vie politique
française depuis
plus d'un siècle
des courants qu'on appelle démocrates
pour simplifier
un grand courant central un grand socle
centrale
qui porte une philosophie que il est à
peu près le seul à porter à assumer
jusqu'au bout et je vais prendre le mot
le plus simple pour la définir une
philosophie humaniste
ceux qui pensent que l'homme n'est pas
au service de l'économie mais que
l'économie devrait être au service de
l'homme ceux qui pensent que il est
improbable et absurde de dire qu'on va
multiplier les solidarités y compris
financières mais qu' on ne produira pas
les biens les richesses qui permettent
d'assumer ces solidarités là et vous
voyez que cette cette volonté de réunir
en une seule toutes les
tout ce qui ferait tout ce qui fait le
la volonté historique de la france qu'on
a appelé tour à tour république
démocratie cela même idée
c'est à dire pour pour aller un tout
petit peu plus loin j'aime beaucoup la
définition qu un philosophe de le grand
philosophe de notre famille politique
qui s'appelle marc sangnier il ya déjà
très longtemps presque un siècle a donné
de la démocratie il a dit la démocratie
c'est l'organisation sociale qui porte à
son plus haut la conscience et la
responsabilité des citoyens
cette idée civique là que nous ne sommes
pas des consommateurs
uniquement nous ne sommes pas des
producteurs uniquement nous ne sommes
pas des sujets sommes pas là uniquement
pour obéir cette idée selon laquelle
nous sommes coresponsables du destin du
pays voilà la philosophie politique que
porte cette famille politique ça se
trouve je sais pas tout à fait fini mais
je vous réponds après il se trouve que
pendant des décennies on a dit on a
voulu effacer cette famille politique et
on a dit tout ceci n'existe pas ce qui
compte c'est droite ou gauche il se
trouve que aucune des raisons que je
viens d'invoquer devant vous ne peuvent
être comment dirais-je
expliquer et éclairer par la
bipolarisation
est donc cette famille politique qui
pendant longtemps a été minoritaire que
vous l'avez dit gentiment que j'ai
défendue au long de ma vie politique en
prenant des risques parfois je reconnais
déraisonnable en tout cas pour ceux qui
font carrière mais bon des risques
personnels et politiques pour cette
famille dont je portais la
responsabilité et se trouve qu'on a
réussi en 2017 par l'alliance avec men
acron à l'installer comme majoritaire il
faut maintenant qu'elles s'organisent
parce que les temps exige que cette
famille soit présente et qu'elle soit
forte et c'est ce que nous allons faire
et à côté de ça vous avez par exemple
l'ancien premier ministre edouard
philippe qui crée son mouvement lui
aussi pour soutenir emmanuel macron
qu'est-ce qui vous divise qu'est ce qui
vous rapproche avec edouard philippe on
a l'impression que ce qui nous divise
les plus importants non je
je récuse absolument ce genre de vision
et doit philippe et moi nous avons une
différence politique depuis longtemps
c'est que l'a exprimé à beaucoup de
reprises
sont son
son l'idée en tout cas laventure dans
laquelle il s'est reconnu c'est celle de
l'ump c'est à dire
une famille politique qui affirmait que
la droite et le centre c'était la même
chose
et moi comme vous savez j'ai refusé
cette interprétation j'ai refusé cette
cet embrigadement pour au contraire
défendre l'idée que je vient d'exprimer
devant vous que il ya une droite elle a
parfaitement le droit d'exister et on
peut travailler avec elle il ya une
gauche on ya plusieurs gauches tailleur
et plusieurs droites et ils ont droit d
exister on peut travailler avec un
certain nombre d'entre elles est sans
doute est ce nécessaire est cependant
il y à un courant central qui a son
identité et son originalité qui a son
message qui a sa philosophie et qui a sa
nécessité historique et donc c'est sur
ce point de le voir philippe a dit je
suis un homme de droite moi je suis un
homme du centre si vous voulez que que
ça rende compte de différence c'en est
une mais on va mais ça veut dire ça veut
dire que l'accusation pourrait faire
campagne pour emmanuel macron ensemble
sans aucun doute en tout cas moi je
ferai campagne pour emmanuel macron et
je ferai quand si le ci décide de se
présenter ou quand il aura décidé de se
présenter et je ferai campagne avec tous
ceux qui décideront de soutenir le même
candidat et la même démarche politique
parce que y'a le candidat ça compte
énormément on vote pas pour une idée en
vogue pour une personne mais les idées
ça compte aussi et tout ce que j'ai vu
depuis cinq ans dans le
dans les choix dans les affirmations du
président de la république correspondent
en profondeur à cet engagement-là de qui
qui se retrouvent dans des hommes comme
un d'ascom mendès-france comme jacques
delors
comme le
tout ce qu'ils avaient dans la vie
politique française
7 ces grands choix humaniste la
france culture politique grégory
philipps alors je le disait françois
bayrou depuis septembre 2020 vous êtes
haut commissaire au plan sous l'autorité
directe du président de la république
votre mission c'est d'offrir des
perspectives d'imaginer la france dans
dix vingt ou trente ans et comme chaque
samedi j'accueille dans ce studio
l'historien nicolas rousseau lié bonjour
nicolas bonjour et c'est évidemment
votre regard d'historien qui nous
intéressent elles remontent assez loin
cette notion de plomb oui effectivement
j'aimerais bien saisir l'occasion de
l'invitation de françois bayroux haut
commissaire au plan comme vous l'avez
dit gregory pour s'interroger sur ce
drôle de retour le drôle de retour de ce
mot de cette chose qui s'appelle le plan
parce que ça fait quand même déjà un
moment qu'on avait oublié le mot le mot
avait été remplacé par celui de
stratégie quand dans l'expression est un
stratège peu près trente ans qu'on ne
parlait plus vraiment de plan donc
l'idée comme le mot semblait bien bel et
bien enterrée or je pense qu'il lui
restait toujours une dimension de
prestige de d'où vient cette notion de
prestige alors cette notion de prestige
il faudrait rappeler en fait quels ont
été les grandes heures de la
planification ça presque un côté presque
légendaire aujourd'hui si on se souvient
du premier plan de 1946 associé au nom
de de jean monnet alors pourquoi cet
aspect légendaire pas parce que vous
aviez grégory d'abord le côté
reconstruction on se retrouve tous les
manches vous aviez le côté un état fort
efficace qui finalement se fixe un
nombre assez limité d'objectifs pour le
premier plan de 1946 s'appuie sur les
nationalisations secteur public très
important le contrôle des prix et dans
une certaine mesure même une mesure
assez importante ça marche c'était aussi
vous aviez le côté consensus qu'on peut
appeler le consensus dès 1945
communistes et socialistes sortie de la
résistance voit dans la planification
en quelque sorte la première étape vers
une société socialiste est peut-être
plus surprenants de gaulle les
gaullistes une partie de la droite se
félicite aussi de la planification c'est
eux qui finalement la porte parce qu'ils
y voient un gage de puissance y compris
sur les aspects militaires une puissance
nationale vous aviez aussi
les partenaires sociaux les commissions
de modernisation associées au plan
permettait cette rencontre entre
patronat syndicats ouvriers s'étaient
pas toujours facile mais il y avait
l'idée que une démocratie sociale était
à l'horizon enfin cerise sur le gâteau
vous aviez des choses concrètes qui ont
marqué les esprits très intéressant de
voir que par exemple tgv tu peux quand
même être considérée comme un symbole de
succès le tgv a été décidée dans le
sixième plan au tout début des années 70
quand il est encore temps si je puis
dire de faire un plan et d'y croire
c'est à dire avant les crises du pétrole
alors pourquoi est ce que un temps en
tout cas on a abandonné cet instrument
oui alors pourquoi abandonner un
instrument qui marche aussi bien bien
cet instrument marche parce que il est
fondamentalement associé à un certain
type d'état un état qu'on pourrait
qualifier de souverains et régalien à la
fois et ça ça a été abandonné à partir
des années 80 et surtout au début des
années 90 ce qu'est ce que vous aviez
vous alliez d'un côté le mot
décentralisation si vous avez des
régions qui sont avec des assemblées des
présidents démocratiquement élus vous
avez une avancée démocratique
donc vous pouvez pu faire un plan à
paris jacobin il faut maintenant
négocier ce plan donc c'est ce qu'on
appelle les contrats état région il faut
négocier avec les collectivités locales
vous avez un détricotage par le bas et
puis à la même époque vous remarquerez
un début des années 90 l'union
européenne la france peut plus se
permettre de faire dans son coin à
l'abri de son hexagone un plan pour elle
toute seule elle doit forcément se
concerter avec la commission de
bruxelles et là vous avez plutôt un
détricotage par le haut et tout ça c'est
dans un cadre un contexte tout à fait
important le contexte de privatisation
du recul du secteur public industriel la
mondialisation
l'idée au fond qu'un état ne peut plus
être conçue comme supérieur comme
c'était le cas en 45 c'est presque
ontologique ils étaient considérés comme
supérieurs au marché lui même parce que
le marché était considéré comme
déficient si si je vous suis tout a
changé alors pourquoi le retour du plan
aujourd'hui tout a changé alors
effectivement pourquoi revenir aux mots
de plans j'y vois deux raisons la
première raison c'est parce que quand on
a abandonné le plan au début des années
90 en fait au même moment on a multiplié
des petits plans comme des petits pains
on a multiplié des plans sectoriels un
plan pour l'université 2001 plan cancer
un plan contre la pauvreté tout chaque
sujet étant tout à fait bien sûr
légitime mais du même coup l'état a
confié son action publique aux modèles
des agences et les plus célèbres et qui
sont très critiqués ces les ars les les
agences régionales de santé du coup il y
a un impératif qui apparaît depuis la
crise qu vite c'est l'impératif de la
coordination comment coordonner tous ces
petits plants qui ont tendance à avoir
étendu l'état en horizontalité mais plus
de verticalité et puis enfin laden
deuxième raison alors là ça rejoint
l'idée de notre émission grégory c'est à
dire la campagne présidentielle je pense
que la deuxième raison est les plus
polis plus politique elle est plus
profonde dans notre élection
présidentielle la convention implicite
c'est que nous choisissons un président
ou une présidente à condition que on
donne à ce président toute une série de
deux d'horizon de d'annoncés de
promesses qu'il a pu faire on
n'imaginerait pas un président ou une
présidente
en quelque sorte dotée de toutes nos
attentes les attentes des électeurs et
qui ensuite ne pourrait pas embrayer sur
une administration en état de marche si
on nous disait que l'administration ne
suis pas derrière ça serait un véritable
problème donc je pense que le retour du
mot peut-être la chose c'est plus
compliqué mais le mot de plan est un peu
le retour d'un mot qui est ici pour
conjurer tous les doutes que nous avons
sur la puissance publique et que
certains appellent l'impuissance
publique merci nicolas rousseau lié
françois bayrou en tant que haut
commissaire au plan comment est ce que
vous comptez ou pouvait peser sur le
débat public en france d'abord je trouve
que ce que nicolas rousselet viens de
dire est très juste et comme et comment
on fait pas souvent de compliments dans
l'est dans les émissions fin que comme
moi on puisse on puisse faire celui là
bon
je vais le dire à mme à ma manière
d'abord c'est il est tout à fait juste
que ce camp ce que nous avons voulu
relever c'est le mot et l'ambition
contenus dans
danser dans cette tradition du
commissariat au plan
c'est tout à fait exact alors évidemment
le plan aujourd'hui n'est pas le même
qu'il était en
1945 mais je voudrais vous dire ce qui
est pour moi essentiel est essentielle
d'abord l'idée qu'on puisse ré
introduire dans le débat public la
réflexion à 10 20 30 ans
alors que le débat public que vous
l'avez souligné vous même vous pousse à
l'immédiateté les chaînes de télévision
continue les réseaux sociaux les
emballements journalistique y en a comme
vous savez
tout ça tout cela pousse à l'immédiateté
on veut des mesures tout de suite pour
une situation que la découverte hier
matin et qu'il faut avoir résolu demain
soir
donc
ayons cette perspective 10 20 30 ans
la chine
a un plan qui est un plan à 30 ans dans
laquelle ils décident secteur par
secteur c'est la puissance du parti
communiste chinois et dieu sait que je
ne les envie pas comme type
d'organisation
mais la perspective est très très
importante deuxièmement
en effet ce que ce que nicolas rousseau
lui a dit être extrêmement justes mais
on peut aller je crois encore un peu
plus loin dans cette analyse
pourquoi est ce que l'idée de plants
avaient disparu
l'idée d'un plan auquel on réfléchit
ensemble est en tout cas de la
perspective qu'on se donne pourquoi
parce que le plan suppose une idée de
l'intérêt général
et pendant des années et des années
cette idée avait disparu depuis reagan
thatcher pour simplifier au profit d'une
certitude ou d'une idéologie ou si on
voulait comme on est à france culture on
peut dire une méta idéologie une
idéologie souterraine qui était l'idée
que
e.on avait pas à définir par une
démarche commune ce que devait être le
choix des entreprises
que je l'avais dit j'ai écrit ça ya très
longtemps
l'idée s'était introduite que au fond
l'intérêt général n'étaient pas autre
chose que la somme des intérêts
particuliers
irene le plan celle inverse de ça et
c'est exactement l'inversé de ça c'est à
dire l'idée que oui il y à des enjeux
nationaux en particulier pas seulement
nationaux européens aussi il y à des
enjeux de société et de civilisation qui
devraient orienter les efforts de toute
la communauté nationale publique et
privée et on avait complètement rompu
avec cette idée et permettez-moi de le
dire y compris à gauche
qui normalement idéologiquement aurait
dû être sur une autre ligne mais y
compris à gauche l'idée s'était
introduite depuis en effet les années 80
que bon le le plan ça marchait pas vous
souvenez de ce congrès du parti
socialiste
incroyable dans laquelle michel rocard
défendez l'idée que entre le plan et le
marché il n'y avait rien et où laurent
fabius dans une formule le génial
quelques-unes était monté à la tribune
pour dire michel rocard vous trompez
entre le plan il marche et il y a le
socialisme et moi je crois que cette
cette nécessité de trouver alors ma
réponse ne serait pas la même mais de
trouver l'intérêt général qui s'exprime
dans la société et qui permet la phrase
que je vais dire est pour moi très
importante même si on n'a pas le temps
de bien insister
le l'état devrait être non seulement
stratège définir l'intérêt général mais
l'état devrait être fédérateur c'est à
dire que les grands acteurs de la
société et les entreprises privées
autant que l'action publique devraient
être invités à partager ses objectifs je
vais en citer un qui est très simple qui
est pour nous une
programme de travail ça n'est pas
possible que la france soit en déficit
commercial de 60 milliards d'euros par
an alors que l'allemagne est en excédent
commercial de 250 milliards d'euros ce
n'est pas possible parce qu'il n'est pas
vrai que les allemands soient
tellement plus fort tellement mieux
organisés tellement plus adaptée aux
évolutions du temps que nous ne le
sommes c'est parce que nous avons
renoncé peu à peu il ya une dérive on a
laissé partir
l'activité on a laissé partir la
production alors justement françois
bayroux parce qu' il s' agit en tant que
haut commissaire au plan d'avoir un
regard à 10 20 ou 30 ans et ce que vous
disiez à l'instant et je vous présente
nos ramadi qui vient d'entrer dans ce
studio productrice de l'émission sous
les radars sur france culture juste
avant cette émission
n'aura tout à l'heure vous évoquiez ce
manque de main d'oeuvre dans certains
secteurs avec certaines régions vous
aviez pris l'exemple de cherbourg je
crois qu'ils peinent à recruter et vous
avez une question pour françois bayroux
sur sur ce thème là oui justement
françois bayrou bonjour nous avons donc
explorer les raisons qui conduisent en
fait à un manque de main d'oeuvre
chronique dans certains certains
territoires français on voit à quel
point l'industrie la construction le
tertiaire notamment la restauration mais
tous les métiers du soin en fait ont des
difficultés à recruter c'est maintenant
ça fait plusieurs semaines qu'on en
parle est-ce que vous haut commissaire
au plan vous considérez que il faut
augmenter substantiellement les salaires
danser danser dans ces sphères
d'activité ou alors diminuer le temps de
travail pour attirer les candidats
pardonnez moi je crois que c'est
les remèdes magiques comme ça c'est une
pensée fausse c'est une boussole fausses
lorsque la candidate du parti socialiste
dit je vais doubler le salaire des
enseignants
j'ouvre les guillemets je vais doubler
le salaire d'enseignant au moins
mais c'est c c'est purement et
simplement une promesse fallacieuse
il n'y aura pas d'augmentation durable
des salaires s'il n'y a pas
d'augmentation durable de la production
c'est vrai entreprise par entreprise
mais c'est vrai pour l'ensemble de la
société
il n'y aura
c'est une illusion que de prétendre le
contraire alors quels sont les problèmes
que nous avons et nous allons
écrire
pour le plan avec le plan une note sur
ce sujet sur le sujet de la deûle a
en effet de la préparation de
l'orientation vers l'emploi
1 la formation
2 une organisation du travail
3 le gouvernement s'y emploie
essayez d'éviter les trappes à
inactivité
essayer d'éviter aussi si on peut les
trappes à bas salaires parce qu'on a
organisées toutes les choses dans la
société depuis longtemps pour que depuis
longtemps depuis des gouvernements
successifs pour que le
le le smic
soit totalement dépourvu de charge de
sorte que les employeurs ne font pas
sortir leurs salariés du smic parce que
sans ça ils vont avoir des avalanches de
charges sur c'est comme ça qu'ils le
ressentent et donc on fait des trappes à
bas salaires on fait aussi des trappes à
inactivité
le
très grand nombre d'entreprises dans ma
région donc par exemple dans le bâtiment
où de jeunes garçons absolument capables
absolument doux et viennent et disent
moi je veux un contrat de quatre mois et
pas plus parce qu'après je veux
reprendre
d'autres activités d'autres d'autres
expériences
mais ça c'est des trappes à inactivité
et donc
les salaires augmenteront
doivent augmenter
au fur et à mesure que la capacité de
production augmentent et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je défends le fait qu' on
facilite à l'extrême ce qui est
participation et intéressement
le bénéfice de l'entreprise devrait
bénéficier devrait aller beaucoup plus
facilement encore vers les salariés
qu'il ne va aujourd'hui on a fait des
progrès je suis persuadé qu'on peut
aller encore plus loin dans ce sens là
et que c'est probablement le moyen que
chacun mesure chacun des salariés mesure
le le bénéfice qu'il peut attendre de
son engagement professionnel françois
bayrou je rebondis sur ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure en évoquant cette
promesse d'anne hidalgo de quasiment
doubler le salaire des enseignants
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
dans ce début de campagne
les promesses pleuvent comme à
gravelotte c'est exactement ça et tout
le monde le sait il n'ya pas un seul de
ceux qui nous écoutent qui ne sache ça
les promesses sont multipliés on
enseveli la campagne sous des promesses
qui sont tout aussi intenable les unes
que les autres et on y ajoute des
promesses de baisses d'impôts baisses de
taxes le les mêmes candidats ou
candidates
10 en même temps on va multiplier les
salaires
arrêtons-nous une seconde parce que
on est sûr sur une radio qui est très
écouté par mes collègues enseignants
on ne peut pas augmenter le salaire des
enseignants sans augmenter les retraites
il ya une loi qui ne loi
légal qui crée un lien de solidarité
entre le salaire d'activité et le
montant de la pension et on ne peut pas
augmenter
en raison de la fonction publique de la
grille de la fonction publique on peut
pas augmenter les uns sans augmenter les
autres le personnel de santé par exemple
et donc ce sont des promesses
fallacieuses on se on se moque du monde
avec une désinvolture
inciviques
c'est pas de cette manière que j'imagine
l'engagement politique j'entends ce que
vous dites est à la fois on voit dans
les sondages par exemple que le pouvoir
d'achat est la priorité absolue des
français et qu'il faut faire quelque
chose parce que quand on va à la pompe
par exemple payer son plein d'essence
certains se privent d'autres dépenses
vous avez vu que le gouvernement vient
précisément de prendre des décisions
sonnantes et trébuchantes
pour aider ceux qui ont des difficultés
précisément au passage à la pompe est ce
que vous craignez françois bayroux si la
question du pouvoir d'achat ne
s'améliore pas qu'on voit éclore à
nouveau un mouvement type gilet jaune
avant la campagne avant la
présidentielle
je ne pense pas que le mouvement des
gilet jaune soient
limités à cette question du pouvoir
d'achat je pense que c'est un mouvement
très profond
qui doit être prise en compte de manière
sérieuse pas dans ces manifestations qui
sont parfois
parfois scandaleusement violentes ou à
d'autres moments répétitives et
agaçante sur pour l'observateur
inattentif sur bien des sujets
en revanche je pense qu'il ya une
question il ya plusieurs questions 1 ce
qu'on a appelé le mouvement des gilet
jaune ça n'est pas un mouvement des
marginaux dans la société française
c'est un mouvement de ceux qui étaient
au coeur de la société française
salariés salariés du du bas de la
pyramide ou du milieu de la pyramide
retraités ruraux
rurbains c'est à dire ce qui faisait
depuis des décennies
comment dirais-je le le socle le plus
solide de la société française
et donc
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont tu peu à peu
le sentiment et il n'y a pas de doute
que
il ya des décisions des mesure où on n'a
pas fait attention à ce qu'ils étaient
en train de se passer si vous si vous me
si vous m'interrogez d'un nouveau tout à
l'heure dans une dernière question je
vous le dirai je vous dirais quoi il
nous reste deux minutes françois voilà
mais ont fini mais ils ont ils ont peu à
peu été envahies de la certitude du
manque de considération
et c'est pourquoi je pense que une des
décisions ou une des
désorientations les plus fortes du
président de la république a été le
grand débat c'est à dire prendre des
heures et des dizaines d'heures et des
centaines d'heures pour parler d'homme à
homme les yeux dans les yeux avec tous
ceux qui étaient là quelle que soit
leur statut y avait des élus et puis
j'avais des gilet jaune
et donc manque de considération et puis
aussi un certain nombre d'idées qui
étaient des idées de facilité et je
tiens la promesse que je vous avais fait
je pense que il s'est introduit dans un
certain nombre d'esprits l'idée qu'il y
avait un truc assez facile pour résoudre
des problèmes des finances publiques et
que ce truc c'était qu'on allait
remplacer
les impôts directs par des taxes sur les
carburants en même temps parce que ça
faisait plaisir aux écologistes
et quand même c'était drôlement rentable
pour pour le portefeuille de l'état
françois bayrou il nous reste je pense
que cette idée était une idée feu
dangereux et fausses françois bayrou il
nous reste 30 secondes et vous évoquez
les les promesses des différents
candidats
yannick jadot qui évoque une sortie du
nucléaire dans les 20 ans qui viennent
vous êtes haut commissaire au plan est
ce que c'est possible c'est impossible
et je pense qu'il le sait et c'est
démagogique
je pense que si on réfléchit à la
question nous avons produit une note
avec le haut commissariat au plan il ya
six mois qui a je crois à changer le
climat autour du nucléaire
cette note elle dit qu elle dit quelque
chose d'extrêmement simple si l'on veut
tenir notre engagement de produire de
l'électricité sans émettre de gaz à
effet de serre il faut à la fois
conduire l'augmentation du renouvelable
et dans le pilot table quand ya pas de
vent n'y a pas de vente quand il n'ya
pas de soleil a pas de soleil donc il
faut à la fois du renouvelable est ce
qu'on appelle du pilotable le seul
pilotable qui n'émettent pas de gaz à
effet de serre en dehors de
l'hydroélectricité qui est limité c'est
le nucléaire il n'y a pas d'autres
solutions il faut prendre des décisions
rapides si l'on veut éviter à la société
la crise de l'énergie qui se
dessine à l'horizon françois béraud
merci beaucoup vous étiez en duplex de
votre ville de pau